what's up guys so as you guys already
know GPU prices are insane right now and
they aren't budging at all new cards
from Nvidia like ampere and Turing's
were expected to somewhat help the
situation right now it doesn't seem like
any new cars from Nvidia are coming up
anytime soon this news first showed up
on Tom's Hardware who claimed that
anyone hoping for something big from
Nvidia to be announced at GDC will
unfortunately be disappointed at first
it was thought that ampere was going to
be the new gaming oriented card and
cheering might be the new mining card
but now this article is saying that
ampere will actually a successor to
Volta and Turing is what's going to be
the next gaming graphics card this dust
makes some sense because there is no
need for Nvidia to push our new series
of consumer cards right now there isn't
any competition for an Nvidia except for
Intel first but seriously envious
current graphics cards are more than
enough for average gamers right now and
invidious dominating graphics card
market right now and have been
dominating for quite a while so they
don't need fun at all so when is turning
going to come well Turing is rumored
that I won't even begin to be
mass-produced until June so
unfortunately these graphics cards
aren't coming out all the way till July
or even August which is quite a while
away from now so when can we expect a
price drop then well honestly I don't
think prices are going anywhere anytime
soon cheering an ampere inches some hope
for a price drop but now that doesn't
seem to be the case anymore for a while
at least as we know RAM prices are also
really high and GPUs do need the RAM and
so that doesn't help either so right now
it seems that we're just stuck and
really can't do anything about it but
there is still one thing that makes you
question Tom's Hardware GPU 1 or 2 is a
crucial chip that is used in the GTX
1080 and some other high-end at ground
cards the production of this chip was
halted a few months ago so I'm not sure
what that means
I don't think India has an F inventory
plus all the way to in July especially
with the high crazy high demand
right now so I don't know what they're
planning to do honestly I feel that
Nvidia must release Turing or whatever
next consumer-level GPU sooner in there
to avoid running out of inventory of
current generation GPUs so that is
definitely something to keep in mind and
what about AMD we haven't really heard
anything from AMD since the release of
Vega the only thing we can foresee is
AMD Navi but that isn't even coming to
out till the end of this year or even
next year also that is supposed to be a
high-level series so worthy budget
options from AMD like the 600 series so
that is something to keep an eye out to
so that is something to keep an eye out
for as well because that may bring more
value to the market right now
so overall unfortunately that 2080 and
other 2000 series cars may not be coming
to other later this year as in the
second half and as a result GPU prices
are probably not going anywhere for a
really long time
unless AMD brings out something soon
however even then graphics cards are
gonna be overpriced until RAM prices it
or normalize however AMD does bring out
new series of cards quite frequently so
we may see something from them soon that
may help the current situation but
that's pretty much all I have for you
guys this time like always make sure to
post what you guys are thinking in the
comments down below like do you think a
new series of graphics cards will help
the current situation of graphics card
prices and when do you guys think Turing
and Empire and Walter will come out from
Nvidia and the 600 series and Navi come
off from AMD everything is really in the
dark still so it's really hard to
speculate but make sure I post what you
guys think I read all my comments and
I'm curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts but
anyways if you liked this video they
make sure to drop a like and if you guys
loved it and would like to see more
videos just like this then consider
subscribing and hit it up and hitting
that Bell notification as well but until
next time bye
[Music]